observa la lámina de mi álbum de
preescolar se han convertido en las
profesoras de todo un país durante los
últimos seis meses
suar y carla le han estado dando clases
a los niños de preescolar por televisión
esperamos pronto vernos en los salones
a los colegios mexicanos siguen cerrados
en un intento por detener los contagios
de kobe 19 nadie sabe cuándo volverán a
abrir
carla es profesora en un barrio de bajos
recursos en ciudad de mexico le
preocupan sus estudiantes tratamos de
que todos tengan acceso en cuanto al
contenido de lo que hacemos
existen variedad de este medios en donde
pueden encontrar estos programas en
internet en la televisión en el radio
estamos muy preocupadas por nuestros
niños que no tienen acceso
a ninguna de estas nuevas estrategias
que se están tomando y si estamos
preocupadas por ellos porque pues no
sabemos en lo que están viviendo en casa
estas estrategias puestas en marcha con
urgencia en abril se están implementando
a largo plazo y según el ministerio de
educación podrían incluso extenderse
después de la crisis sanitaria muchas de
las cosas que ustedes van a hacer para
iniciar el ciclo escolar
es la educación del futuro
la forma en que se relacionan con sus
alumnas y alumnos a distancia pero para
un tercio de los niños mexicanos el
futuro aún es incierto
amatitlán un pueblo como tantos otros
perdidos en la inmensidad del méxico
rural aquí todos trabajan en el campo
hay poco o ninguna cobertura de teléfono
móvil y mucho menos de internet luz y
tiene 7 años pasan la mayor parte del
tiempo cuidando a su hermano menor o
jugando con sus primos extraño y salón
extraño
después la estación
mis maestros
quiero dar clases para enseñarme a leer
plenamente que me enseñan mis papás a
leer pero no puede la suscripción en la
televisión cuenta 11 dólares al mes
sus padres la pagan cuando pueden
costearlo pero a veces la electricidad
no funciona
benita a la derecha en madre de tres
hijos es una de las pocas personas de la
ciudad que tiene un smartphone puede
acceder a internet comprando una tarjeta
prepagada filamento a las 10 de la
mañana mañana a las 10 en terceros con
25 pesos puedo comprarle soy de comer
unos huevitos son o algo mis tortillas
pues significa mucho para nosotros aquí
hoy las mujeres de amatitlán se dieron
cita frente a la escuela para hablar del
futuro de sus hijos la última fecha
escrita en el tablero es 19 de marzo de
2020 nadie ha estado aquí desde entonces
las madres están tratando de organizarse
para compartir dispositivos y horas de
internet por ejemplo si se va la luz
compra su ficha de 25 se van a nuestra
guía
ya no hay luz se pierda su ficha tiene
que volver a comprar otra fija aquí el
poco material educativo está
desactualizado y ahora que todo puede
verse por televisión el retraso es
evidente
clase de arte clase de música clase de
inglés y nosotros estas materias aquí no
nos vemos niños están muy adelantadas
como muchas comunidades rurales
amatitlán sea al lado desde el comienzo
de la pandemia para protegerse del
contagio porque no hay clínicas en los
alrededores ya nada ya no han venido
ni doctores enfermeras nada
cuando observamos vamos a igualar lo que
también explica porque el profesor no ha
podido poner un pie en el pueblo durante
seis meses nos reunimos con él en
sumpango a 50 kilómetros de distancia
donde se recupera después de haberse
contagiado de coronavirus marcos tiene
miedo de que sus estudiantes dejen de
estudiar ya desde antes de la pandemia
les costaba mantenerlos en las aulas
pero por lo regular las niñas llegando a
los 14 15 años de la secundaria empiezan
a salir a salirse porque porque ya
encontraron un novio se van con el novio
forman una familia
los niños continúan sus estudios
terminan la secundaria terminan el
bachillerato y algunos se van al
ejército otros más al campo a labores
del campo otros más se casan y se vienen
con sus familias emigran a los estados
unidos otros más se van a otros estados
otros matos desafortunadamente se
pierden y se van en las filas del narco
la crisis sanitaria reveló las dos caras
de méxico un país comprometido con la
educación a distancia a largo plazo
tiene el proceso deja atrás a las
comunidades rurales